l'écologie au coeur des attentions donc
aujourd'hui dix jours avant l'arrêt du
premier réacteur de la centrale de
fessenheim avant le second en juin
alors est-ce une réelle nécessité pour
préserver l'environnement plutôt un
geste politique pour contenter les
écologistes c'est l'objet de notre face
à face et pour en débattre nous sommes
par skype depuis colmar avec andré axe
président de stop fessenheim bonsoir en
face de vous sur un autre plateau à rémy
prud'homme professeur émérite à
l'université de paris xii professeur om
haïti est aussi auteur de le mythe des
énergies renouvelables quand on aime on
ne compte pas aux éditions l'artilleur
messieurs bonsoir
notre défi c'est de réduire le nucléaire
pour augmenter la part du renouvelable
ce sont les mots du président emmanuel
macron dans une interview accordée au
dauphiné libéré on le disait alors selon
vous est ce que c'est vraiment une
réelle priorité aujourd'hui andré hatz
commencer
c'est une priorité c'est à la fois une
priorité économique est fait à la fois
une priorité environnementale économique
parce que la france va bientôt se
retrouver dans le wagon de queue des
énergies renouvelables à force de mettre
tout son argent dans le nucléaire il
faut savoir qu'en france les élites ont
été biberonné au nucléaire ils ne savent
pas raisonner autrement qu'au travers du
nucléaire alors que tous les autres pays
européens nous prouve très bien que l'on
peut s'en passer et on a du mal à
comprendre cet immobilisme
par ailleurs c'est une nécessité au plan
environnemental
parce que bien entendu le nucléaire est
une énergie légèrement décarbonés face
est un avantage mais c'est une énergie
qui produit énormément de déchet et qui
n'est pas plus décarbonés que les
énergies renouvelables
les déchets la france ne sait plus quoi
en faire on va construire de nouvelles
piscines
on va bientôt crouler fut fait masse de
déchets nucléaires nous sommes en train
de creuser notre propre tombe
avec cette énergie du passé et si je dis
énergie du passé c'est qu'il faut bien
avoir à l'esprit qu'une centrale
nucléaire ce n'est rien d'autre qu'une
vieille machine à vapeur vous jouez dans
les années 1850
il y avait les deux bateaux à vapeur et
bien là c'est une machine à vapeur
simplement qui fonctionne avec de
l'uranium que l'on va chercher dans des
pays lointains et contrairement au
discours politique ça n'assure pas
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
rémy prud'homme est ce qu'il faut à tout
prix sortir du nucléaire comme on viens
de l'entendre dans la bouche de andré
hatz 1 je le rappelle président de stop
fessenheim
je ne crois pas en tout cas ce qui
m'apparaît sûr c'est que il n'est pas
sérieux de dire que réduire le nucléaire
c'est contribuer à la lutte contre le
co2 et le réchauffement climatique le
nucléaire ne produisent pas de co2 il
est remplacé par de l'éolien et du
solaire qui ne produisent pas non plus
de co2 mais ce remplacement ne contribue
en rien à réduire le peut du reste le
peu de co2 que rejette la france dans sa
production d'électricité et sur la
question des déchets comme le souligne à
l'instant real alors la question des
déchets depuis très longtemps on serait
devant la plupart des déchets des
centrales nucléaires un nom pas une
durée de vie très longue et ne pose pas
de problème très sérieux il y a une
petite fraction des déchets qui mérite
d'être pour le moment laissé tranquille
on connaît la solution qui est de
déterminer des zones particulièrement
profonde particulièrement sûr
géologiquement et d'entreposer ses
déchets à ce fait un coût qui est
assez raisonnable qui est d'ailleurs
connue qui rentrent dans le calcul du
coût du nucléaire et et sava paraît pas
être un problème insurmontable
puisqu'il est déjà partout surmonter
andré hatz un problème qui n'est pas
insurmontable cette question du
traitement du déchet aujourd'hui selon
rémi prud'hom qu'est-ce que vous comment
est-ce que vous réagissez et les écouter
ça fait 50 ans que les élites nous
raconte qu'on va trouver des solutions
pour gérer les déchets c'est un mensonge
fait un enfant est orienté s'étonner un
aussi grand mensonge que le nuage de
tchernobyl qui s'est arrêtée au dessus
du rhin nous n'avons pas de solution
pour les déchets et je suis surpris que
des personnes de la qualité de mon
interlocuteur n'est pas la lucidité de
voir ce qu'il en est réellement
on va construire des nouvelles piscines
pour stocker ces déchets on ne sait pas
quoi en faire et on voudrait en faire
quoi et stockés à à bure cigéo à bure en
dessous d'une partie argileuse certes
mais en fut au dessus d'une ressources
géothermiques
personne ne peut plus le contester
lorsque les générations futures seront à
la recherche de sources d'énergie parce
que bientôt on va nous manquer elles
iront chercher les générations virons
chercher ses sources et nous ne saurons
pas communiquer avec elle ça
représentera 50 fois cent fois la
distance qui nous sépare des pyramides
il faut bien être il faut bien être
confiante de touche mais j'ai du mal
j'ai du mal à comprendre pourquoi
pourquoi nous voulons à tout prix
poursuivre cette folie de l'énergie
nucléaire tous les autres pays moi
j'habite près de l'allemagne j'habite
près des pays bas lorsque je me déplace
je me rends compte qu'il y a des
éoliennes
je m'arrête un pied d'une éolienne ça
fait pas beaucoup de bruit contrairement
à ce qu'on prétend et il y a également
des panneaux photovoltaïques
et puis nous avons en france un autre
problème auquel nous allons être
confrontés et qui n'existait pas il faut
le reconnaître
à l'époque de la construction des
centrales nucléaires c'est le problème
du terrorisme
figurez-vous que par exemple les
piscines les deux piscines de stockage
des des combustibles irradiés à
fessenheim sont des piscines non d'une
crise et elles se trouvent le long du
grand canal d'alsace givet est
régulièrement donc je peux en parler il
ya régulièrement des péniches des barges
qui s'arrête à hauteur de la centrale
pour attendre d'être récusé
imaginez une personne malveillante à
bord de l'une de ces barges ou de ces
péniches elle tirait la moindre petite
roquette en direction de la piscine
c'est une catastrophe parce que une
piscine qui fouillent de fono on
n'arrive plus à arrêter la rédaction ac
tonique il faut être conscient de cela
et auraient à coup on va laisser on va
on va laisser répond justement rémy
prud'homme à la fois sur effectivement
cette question de terroristes il faut y
penser
et puis au fond pourquoi ne pas
développer les éoliennes
les le photovoltaïque comme le disais à
l'instant andreas oui alors il ya une
première raison pour le nucléaire c'est
que il est décarbonée et donc que agité
l'épouvantail du réchauffement et du co2
est quelque chose qui est malhonnête
puisque en l'occurrence fermer les
centrales nucléaires ne sert
rigoureusement à rien et ne diminue en
rien les rejets de co2 de la france
ceci est un premier point un deuxième
point est que c'est jeter de l'argent
par les fenêtres fermer une centrale en
état de marche comme nucléaire comme
comme comme fessenheim
ça fait penser à un caprice de gosse de
riche qui a un jouet en état de marche
et puis qui le jette où ça fait penser
cette histoire qu'on raconte est
autrefois de marie-chantal qui dont le
nom dont la voiture de sport à un
cendrier qui est plein et qui la change
qui l'âge est il la met de côté pour en
acheter une autre
nous avons des centrales nucléaires je
parle du parc existant la question de de
te construire de nouvelles centrales est
une autre question
mais la question des centrales
existantes qui sont en état de marche
dont l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire nous
garantit qu'elles ne présentent pas de
danger 7 ces centrales là qui sont
totalement amorti produisent de
l'électricité à un coût qui est
extrêmement bas a un coût qui est de 20
ou 25 euros du mégawattheures nous les
remplaçons par des centrales éoliennes
ou par des centrales photovoltaïques qui
produisent de l'électricité à un coût
qui est 4,5 10 fois plus élevé le
résultat c'est que nous allons augmenter
les factures d'électricité
elles ont déjà beau
augmenter il ya quelques mois vient
encore d'augmenter de 7 ou 8 ou 10 % au
cours de l'année passée
andrea qui va payer vous et moi mais en
particulier les gens les plus pauvres
il ya quelque chose de recife andrea sur
cette question financière exactement en
plus en plus il ya de la démagogie dans
votre propos monsieur j'avais vraiment
du mal à vous comprendre ne savez-vous
pas que l'électricité nucléaire à young
boys sera vendu à 120 euros alors que
simultanément les énergies renouvelables
est actuellement aux alentours de 40 50
euros
bientôt on va être un coût trois fois
moindre il faut comprendre que le coût
du nucléaire ne cesse d'augmenter et que
film culte animant le coût des énergies
renouvelables ne cesse de baisser
eh bien c'était s'était fait ciseaux
nous l'avons déjà dépassé je suis
surpris qu'un professeur d'économie ne
sache pas ça mais je suis surpris
d'autres choses monsieur c'est que vous
n'avez pas à l'esprit qu'il ya eu depuis
40 ans un bombardement neutronique aller
à l'intérieur des réacteurs nucléaires
et le réacteur et l'appel pièces d'une
fente d'une centrale que l'on peut pas
remplacer ce bombardement neutronique
pardonnez moi d'être un peu technique
qu'est-ce qu'il va provoquer il va faire
un passage de la ductilité à la
fragilité des métaux et ce passage de la
ductilité à la fragilité des métaux
augmente énormément le risque et moi je
ne peux pas accepter que sa foi les
pouvoirs que sa foi les riches
je ne peux pas accepter qu'on leur fasse
subir le risque nucléaire parce que
bientôt les aciers des centrales ne
tiendront plus coup
quant à la fn elle n'est pas du tout sur
le registre que vous aviez évoqué
monsieur l'asn
au contraire elle nous dit que les
épreuves pour le grand carénage seront
beaucoup plus complexe coûteront
énormément cher
et ceci depuis qu'il y a eu le début de
la catastrophe de fukushima
l'afm a modifié les paramètres de
sécurité ce qui est une bonne chose il
faut savoir fait pendant qu'il y a aussi
des problèmes par la fuite pour le
démantèlement parce que j'aimerais
j'aimerais bien que peut-être qu'on en
parle aussi ce démantèlement alors
béziers et rémy prud'homme vous répondra
ensuite sur le démantèlement justement
alors le démantèlement je prends
l'exemple de facebook parce que j'ai
jamais étudié ce document le plan de
démantèlement de la centrale nucléaire
de fessenheim est bien qu est ce que je
veux faire sdf pour faire des économies
de bouts de chandelles et df veut
laisser sur place les fondations qui
font qu'ils descendent jusqu'à 3 mètres
50 sous le niveau du sol et qui viennent
affleurer la nappe phréatique et elle
veut les remplir avec les gravats en
béton dont certains feront irradiés de
la centrale nucléaire
ce qui veut dire que les générations
futures vont constater quoi elles vont
constater une irradiation de la plus
grande nappe phréatique ne rock qui
peuvent justement sous la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim
alors nous ce que nous proposons fait
que celle sénat devienne un laboratoire
du démantèlement nous proposons que pour
le réacteur numéro 1 on fasse un
démantèlement scientifique c'est à dire
si vous préférez chirurgicale justement
pour pouvoir faire un constat réel et
non pas théorique du vieillissement déjà
fier peut-être que je me suis trompé en
disant que 40 ans c'est le passage de la
ductilité à la fragilité
peut-être que ses 42 ans peut-être que
ces 35 on le verra avec précision à ce
moment là andré hatz et pour le réacteur
numéro 2 par non mais moi je veux juste
terminée on va laisser la parole à
monsieur prudhomme ensuite pour pouvoir
chiffrer les coûts réels parce qu'edf
n'a pas suffisamment provisionné donc
rémy prud'homme sur la question du
démantèlement vous
suppose que vous n'en voulez pas puisque
vous voulez conserver finalement cette
centrale nucléaire n'est en moi comment
réagissez vous justement à cette
question là aux propos d'abord sur la
question de la sécurité je vois que mon
interlocuteur
on sait plus que les ultras spécialiste
de la sn moi j'en sais un peu moins que
et donc je crois ce qu'ils me disent
quand ils me disent que on peut
parfaitement faire fonctionner des
centrales comme fessenheim
alors ils se demandent en effet un
certain nombre de deux d'ajouts en
particulier à la suite de l'inondation
de fukushima comme de multiplier par
deux ou trois le nombre de deux
centrales au diesel pour de produire de
l'électricité en cas d'incident je pense
que c'est des choses raisonnables
tu ne coûte pas très cher et j'en
reviens à ce que je disais à savoir que
actuellement faire fonctionner une
centrale comme fessenheim et toutes les
centrales qui sont en état de
fonctionner en france produit de
l'électricité un cookie extrêmement bas
vous n'avez pas très bien compris ce que
j'ai dit puisque vous mettez en avant le
coût de including les pointes est une
centrale nucléaire à construire mais
fessenheim n'est pas une centrale
nucléaire à construire
c'est une centrale construite
l'essentiel n'est il pas trop car
l'essentiel l'essentiel du coût est un
coût d'investissement à partir du moment
où l'investissement est effet il est là
et les seuls coûts sont des coûts
d'entretien de fonctionnement d'achat
d'uranium pour à peu près 4 % du coût
total
donc il n'y a il est ridicule de
comparer le coût de fonctionnement de
fessenheim aux coûts de construction et
de fonctionnement de inc les poètes
andré azoulay non je vous jure interrogé
sur rtl
andrée anne est vraiment sur ce point
des coûts vous vous nous présenter les
exemples allemands comme un modèle vous
savez très bien que les ménages
allemands paient leur électricité
exactement deux fois plus cher que nous
la payons en france grâce à notre
nucléaire
vous le savez très bien et vous pouvez
penser qu'il est bon que les français
voient doublé leur facture d'électricité
est ce qu'on tente de doubler d'alors à
l'heure actuelle très lentement
vous pouvez désiré qu'elle double
beaucoup plus rapidement
il ya beaucoup de français en
particulier les plus pauvres
j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus non pas du
tout envie de voir ça on a déjà des cas
en allemagne et on en a ras en france de
précarité énergétique qui pose des
problèmes dramatiques cette question de
la précarité énergétique justement andré
hatz pour répondre moi moi je voudrais
répondre et monsieur l'électricité en
allemagne n'est pas vendu plus cher
qu'en france
la seule différence c'est qu'en france
la moitié du coup se retrouvent sur la
facture d'électricité et autres moitié
des coûts est payé par le contribuable
parce que l'état est à tout bout de
champ on va bien entendu l'état est à
tout bout de champ en train de remplir
de remplir les pertes des deux ddf qui
est au bord de la faillite vous mais
vous le savez bien
non non non complètement rémy prud'homme
alors j'ai juste sur cette question vous
répondez vous comptez vous continuer à
vendre et nos ressources sur ce crash
est complètement in éclatant de dire
tout à leur pardon mais le nucléaire
produit 66 grammes de co2 par
kilowattheure si on prend en
considération le cycle complet il faut
avoir l'honnêteté de dire cela monsieur
si on prend en considération le cycle
complet l'éolien et le photovoltaïque
rejette encore beaucoup plus de co2 que
très peu du reste parce que je nique les
airs en rejettent très peu il n'y a qu'à
regarder la quantité de
béton qui rentre dans une éolienne et la
comparer avec celle qui rentre dans une
centrale nucléaire
mais messieurs on vous dit je reviens
sur la question des subventions à
l'heure actuelle le nucléaire en france
n'a jamais été subventionné les
centrales ont été construites avec des
emprunts notamment auprès de l'étranger
et ses enfants ont tous été remboursés
et malgré cela et des f&a jusqu'à une
date très récente fait des bénéfices et
à verser à celui qui a subventionné
l'état ce qui est vrai c'est que
l'éolien et le photovoltaïque sont
lourdement subventionné ils le sont au
actuellement à hauteur de 7,8 milliards
par an fait rien en allemagne ces 25
milliards
mais ils ne le sont pas par le
contribuable qu'ils le sont par le
consommateur d'électricité
les eaux sont en train de changer et on
a on vient d'introduire un impôt qui
frappent que ces subventions à l'éolien
et au photovoltaïque seront payés par le
contribuable et pas seulement dans le
consommateur d'électricité
mais ici ça n'a pas été le cas messieurs
il nous reste un peu moins d'une minute
je vous propose chaque un vautour de
conclure andré hatz en un mot pour
conclure sur ce débat cette fermeture de
fessenheim donc une bonne chose il faut
continuer dans ce sens là pour vous en
un mot ah oui pour moi nous sommes en
train de faire le premier pas vers la
sortie du nucléaire et se fit est
positif malheureusement la france est
trop timide dans ces domaines alors que
la france dispose d'une façade maritime
qui lui permettrait de développer
beaucoup plus que d'autres et pas
seulement avec l'éolien également avec
l'hydrolien nous n'en avons pas parlé ce
soir qui lui permettrait de développer
énormément les énergies
blâme regardez monsieur vers l'avenir
vous avez peut-être été biberonné au
nucléaire mais ayez le courage de dire
le nucléaire nous a peut-être servi il
ya 50 ans aujourd'hui il est un boulet
pour la france rémy prud'homme pour
conclure le nucléaire un boulet pour la
france qu'est ce que vous répondez à
cela en un mot le nucléaire a été l'un
des atouts de la france parce qu'il lui
a permis d'avoir une électricité bon
marché
c'est l'un des rares domaines dans
lequel la france fait mieux que des pays
comme l'allemagne et casser cet avantage
cas c'est une industrie dans laquelle la
france était en avant qui produisait de
l'électricité à bon marché pour les
entreprises et pour les ménages
c'est un caprice de gosse de riche merci
à tous les deux d'avoir partager vos
points de vue sur notre plateau merci à
vous andrade je rappelle que vous êtes
président de stop fessenheim
vous étiez en direct depuis colmar merci
à vous rémy prud'homme je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur émérite à
l'université de paris xii hauteur de
l'ami des énergies renouvelables quand
on aime on ne compte pas aux éditions de
l'arctique